our next speaker and I just learned this
is actually a good thing she Foster
failed her cat right I just
learned that Foster failed means that
like you failed to get them a new home
you kept took care of them I thought she
like killed the
cat right so she Foster failed her and
her words her cat who apparently
today was really sweet though and then
on top of having this cat she adopted a
13-year-old dog that doesn't even have
eyes yeah that's like really really
sweet so everyone please welcome
JJ all right nice to meet everybody uh
super excited to be here today uh and
just give you guys a little bit of
background of how some sports
organizations teams and leagues are
using data to drive decision-making uh
so I wanted to start off on this slide
uh just because today's presentation is
going to be drawing from some of my
experiences at these different
organizations um but had the opportunity
was working you know Healthcare and
finance before my go-to joke was you
know I was doing the job that I really L
data and insights but it wasn't
necessarily an industry I was super
excited about and passionate about uh so
it was really excited when I had the
opportunity to switch over go and worked
for the 49ers I was there for two very
very losing Seasons they actually ended
up going to the Super Bowl the year
after I left so I like to say all the
work that I did really prepared them for
it you know uh and then I moved over to
New York City I was with the NHL league
offices for about four and a half years
just short of five years uh and now I've
been down here in Orlando never thought
I'd be living in Florida um but I've
been here for about 10 months I'm the
senior director of strategy and
analytics over at Orlando city which
encompasses both our men's and women's
professional soccer team so a lot of my
presentation is actually going to be
about the work that I did at the 49ers
and NHL since I've only been there for
about 10 months we're really building up
a foundation in
Orlando so diving right into it the
reason I wanted to show this slide is I
think it's definitely a misconception I
think before working in sports I was
thinking oh they must have 20 30 people
working on business analytics they
probably have a ton of money or doing a
lot of crazy things
no that is not the case so back in 2016
the 49ers were one of the biggest if not
the biggest analytics team and you'll
see here there's only seven or eight of
us so not a lot of people necessarily so
didn't want to spend a lot of time uh on
this slide in particular but at a very
high level the department was split into
two there's a strategy side and a
business analy or excuse me business
intelligence side and the main role of
that business intelligence team was
really getting data in the right format
in the right place at the right time and
then the strategy side which is what I
was on was then taking that data
starting to find some insights and then
making decisions off of what we were
seeing so also a lot of words on this
slide um but just a little bit uh
information about what I had the
opportunity to work on so working on our
key research programs putting together
event Recaps working on our happy or not
Terminals and then also most importantly
what you'll see as a theme kind of
throughout my career is doing a lot of
data visualization so taking all the
data making it pretty so diving into
some of these examples something that
was really important to me when I was
working there was on fan research uh so
simply put you know obviously we would
send out surveys to our fans learning
about their experiences so I joined back
in 2015 so looking two years prior to
that in
2013 uh the only way that they were
collecting survey data was from
something called the NFL voice of the
fan study and that's something that's
still going on today and it was super
helpful simply put again it was just a
survey that was going out to all the
different teams season ticket members
and single game buyers while I was super
helpful because we could see hey how do
our scores we're getting at eight out of
10 in parking is that good is that bad
we had no idea uh so to be able to
Benchmark ourselves against those other
teams really helped us put into context
some of the results that we were seeing
um but the downside of it is it didn't
really drill down into the level of
detail that we needed so we could see
hey our game Day entertainment scores
came back we scored a 4.5 out of five uh
okay what about Game Day entertainment
what was bad was it the Wi-Fi was it the
halftime entertainment was it the mascot
was it something else
and that survey didn't necessarily dive
into that detail so come 2014 they
introduced their own surveys um by you
know that survey being distributed from
the team you'll see that it went from
6,000 responses for the 2013 season all
the way up to just over 30,000 responses
in
2014 uh and then the way that that
information was then shared back to the
organization was in a 15-page report and
I counted them there was 109 bar charts
and basically the entire report just
looked like that I also apolog to anyone
who is color blind I've definitely
learned that in my experience never use
a red to Green to gray gradient because
I think it's like one out of 10 people
can't tell the difference so I apologize
this was my old work I've not made that
mistake since um but like I mentioned I
joined the organization in 2015 and we
really upgraded and expanded those
surveys to pinpoint those areas of
feedback uh so the survey did get a
little bit longer um so you'll see that
that response rate did go down slightly
I think it could be for a couple of
reasons like I said they weren't winning
a lot so obviously fan engagement is
also going down a little bit as well um
but again really started to upgrade
upgrade that survey so what you'll see
on the Le hand side here is basically a
map of the the Wi-Fi scores for a
particular uh particular game uh and so
uh one of the go-to jokes that my old
boss used to say um was you know
we I think my mic got oh we're good uh
we went to the head of state operations
and said hey our Wi-Fi scores were
really bad for this game and his
response was okay great which one of the
5,000 access points should I fix in the
stadium and so now being able to go in
create Wi-Fi scores on a map to say hey
maybe here some sections that we should
go and check out really help them out
then come 2016 just continue to enhance
that report with some more data
visualizations i' would say they weren't
honestly the most fancy the fanciest
things but something as simple as hey
let's show security screening scores by
gate on a map of all of our gates super
simple concept um or also just enh uh
enhancing our section maps so rather
than just having kind of dots on the map
let's make it a little bit more visual
one of my personal favorites is you'll
have just as many people saying that the
music is too loud as people saying that
it's too quiet you're never going to fix
it uh we also had a seat by seat map
which was super helpful so you could
drill down to that level but uh not that
you take files from things or old work U
but I couldn't find that screenshot uh
this next one this is actually basically
just bar charts again but by just adding
something a little bit more visual makes
that report much more exciting to look
at so if we're looking at our concession
scores let's show a cute little
concession stand so that they can see
some of that information also call out
to myself I made those uh and then
finally sometimes it's just as simple as
adding a picture again it's just a bar
chart it's nothing fancy but rather than
just as you guys saw on the previous
slide it's just a bunch of bars let's
just add a picture to it and then
finally this is also a look at our
departure times out of our parking lots
and so rather than saying hey red lot 5
did this red lot 3 did this blue lot one
did this now I can see oh it's actually
maybe some of the further parking lots
are are scoring a little bit
lower so while the surveys were great it
helped us you know collect a lot of
information give feedback to people we
really got a push from our executive
leadership team to say hey this
information is great but I need it
sooner so we were thinking all right we
send out we have a a game on Sunday we
send out the survey Monday morning we
collect the results put together the
report on Tuesday send everyone the
reports by Wednesday all right well
maybe we can send out the survey Sunday
night right after the game maybe pull
together the reports a little bit sooner
we'll get it to you by Tuesday night
still not good enough and so my boss's
boss at the time his name was Moon he
was going through the airport and you
guys might have seen some of these
terminals before um and basically saw
one of these happy or not terminals at
the airport and it's a super super
simple concept I'm sure you guys have
seen them um as well but it's just
basically four different smiley faces
prompted with a really simple question
uh how is your concessions experience
today so it doesn't give you a lot of
context into why that person's
concessions experience was good or bad
but you'll see that we had 280,000
responses in just one and a half Seasons
uh we even broke happier knut's record
of single responses on a terminal within
a day um but basically place them we had
120 terminals place them in our
concessions our gates guest uh guest
services and bathrooms um and like I
said it's not a lot of detail but by
getting those alerts every 15 minutes I
worked with happy or not to develop
their first mobile app we're able to
push a push notification to that
stakeholder say hey go check out that
area and again while not really detailed
you could go over there and pretty
quickly figure out what was wrong you
know the bathroom was dirty the
concession sign uh line was long the hot
dogs you know they ran out of hot dog
bones or something like that and so it
was just really helpful to in real time
pinpoint those areas of
feedback that being said we would be
remiss to say Obviously Fan Experience
and uh or excuse me fan satisfaction and
onfield performance definitely relate to
each other I I think we always say you
know the beers are colder the hot dogs
are warmer when you're winning um and so
one of the things that you'll see on
this slide and I'll play uh Press Play
in just a second but on the left- hand
side is a match that we played against
Dallas boo I'm an Eagles fan uh where we
we ended up losing that that game and on
the right-and side is when we played the
Jaguars and as you'll see both of these
games started at the same time and again
apologize for the red to Green um but
you'll see on the left hand side these
are all of our concession stands for
that match you'll start to see a lot
more red on the left hand side as
they're losing and losing a little bit
more I'll also say that uh pieces of ADV
or probably the biggest piece of advice
if you see these terminals in a bathroom
do not touch them they are the dirtiest
things
ever um but at a high level one of my
goals was to start to measure hey what
was that impact on onfield performance
on fan satisfaction uh so this was just
a wireframe of a dashboard I started to
put together so we could see based on
our win probability based on the score
of the game how are our happier or not
scores trending so that eventually we
could come to a number hey fans are 10%
more pissed off when we're losing a game
about things that have nothing to do
with it or things like that so
unfortunately I didn't have a chance to
figure out what that number was because
I switched over to look uh work for the
NHL league offices and so pre 2021 I
think I forget what year it was I think
I joined in 2018 2019 I was part of what
was called The Club business and
analytics team and it was a department
that really started out of the finance
department uh and started as a reporting
arm of the business so we're taking a
lot of information especially from our
CFO building that into the reports then
what we started to learn was there was a
ton of other people within the
organization that was doing analytics
but necessarily weren't learning best
practices from each other so post 2021
uh we created basically a centralized uh
analytics team which was called our fan
engagement in analytics team and I was
part of this little arm over here which
is called our fisa team which I'll show
you that layout in just a second but you
see there's fan engagement strategy
growth marketing ticketing analytics
Club strategic initiatives now we're
bringing that all under one umbrella
underneath our CMO Heidi Browning who's
a super awesome person so going into
fisa uh which is a ton of buzzwords and
probably the longest title that I'll
ever have uh but it's basically fan
intelligence strategy and analytics
basically we were doing data uh business
data uh and so you'll see I was a senior
manager of fisa at the time we also had
someone working on digital and social
analytics probably one of the smartest
people I ever meet was our manager of
quantitative analytics and then
ticketing analytics and fan analytics as
well so I worked on a ton while I was at
the league uh was loved all the work
that I got to do I got to translate some
of that survey work that I was doing at
the 49ers and now do it at a League wide
level uh did a lot of data visualization
I ran our Tableau organizational
strategy and then my favorite thing was
actually our in uh in in uh excuse me in
Market club visits so the getting the
opportunity to come in town meet with
the team see what they're doing and work
out with them figure out best practices
create conferences like this we're
bringing all of our NHL clubs together
it was a lot of fun but what was my baby
when I was there was something called
The Tick a Byer Trend study and it's a
very very lengthy word basically it was
a survey that went at all to to all of
our Club season tick members and single
game buyers but we really wanted to
focus specifically on the people who
were purchasing tickets to our uh to our
games so who are they why were they
purchasing tickets in the first place if
they're a seasoned ticket member what
drove that decision are they going to
renew their tickets next year and the
beauty of this project is that our clubs
could then see it's basically the NFL
voice of the fan study at the NHL uh and
so all of our clubs could see the
results for every single Club across the
entire 32 clubs that were that were in
the league um and we really wanted to
design this study to also go over time
so not only hey what's that snapshot of
that year but how are things changing
especially coming out of covid it was
really interesting to see pre-2020 what
were the results what were the trends
and then what we're reing afterwards as
well uh it was a beast of a project for
sure it was actually completely optional
for our clubs to participate uh so
definitely hang my hat on that we were
able to get all 32 clubs to participate
in this study uh so we uh just in the
2021 season well technically 2021 2022
since we go over two years uh we
collected over 165 sample files uh after
d duping cleaning all the data we ended
up sending just a short of a million
surveys uh got about 100,000 surveys
back and then my favorite part of the
job was then taking all that data
building presentation and finding all
those insights so I also counted these
ones but there was just short of about
7,000 slides just that season uh for 58
custom Club presentations as well as
League Glide presentations as well so
some of the some of the information I
have to share with you guys today are
from some of the end of season results
of that 2021 2022 season um but starting
off uh just explaining in case anyone
doesn't know what net promoter score is
it's a pretty simple concept but
basically it's a question that's within
a survey and it just says How likely is
it that you would recommend a specific
brand Team whatever it might be to a
friend family member or colleague pretty
simple question and it's a question on
a0o to 10 scale so if someone gives it a
nine or a 10 that means that they're a
promoter of your product
uh that means you know if they're going
out they're talking about their brand or
excuse me your brand they're saying
something positive they're a promoter of
your specific brand they're seven eight
they're a little bit more passive they
might say something positive they might
say something negative and anyone is six
or below is someone who would be a
detractor that means they're most likely
going to say something negative a net
promoter score is basically a score from
a um a range of negative 100 to 100 and
you calculate that by taking the
percentage of promoters and subtracting
the percentage of detractors
uh and so for example if you get a score
of 100 that means everyone gave you a
nine or a 10 if you get a score of a
negative 100 that means everyone rated
you six and Below you get a score of
zero that doesn't necessarily mean
everyone scored you a seven and an eight
that just means you had an equal number
of people saying that they were a
promoter as they were a detractor so I
wanted to give that background a little
bit before we hop into some of these
slides uh so this is looking at the net
promoter score uh in purple is the 20192
SE uh average score and the other of
ours are basically the four different
ways we sent throughout That season
because obviously we don't want to just
start at the start of the Season or the
end of the season because like we
mention team performance is going to
impact some of those scores even though
the question has nothing to do about
team performance sometimes and so you'll
see unfortunately there was good news
and bad news so bad news was that the
the net promoter score did go down from
the 201920 season but the good news is
it didn't keep going down so it remained
pretty consistent throughout those those
four different
waves then the fun part about this data
is that we can slice and dice it a ton
of different ways and so when we would
put together these presentations uh
basically we would put together for
every single question the overall
results also this slide so the results
by different demographics and then also
a slide to see those by uh each
individual Club as well and so you'll
see uh there's four different kind of
areas that we focused in on demographics
gender generation ticket type and
Country um and this is definitely a
theme that we saw across the board on
almost all of our questions and by that
I mean for gender females were always
had a higher uh satisfaction than males
younger Generations had a higher
satisfaction our single game buyers uh
scored us higher than our season ticket
members did which obviously is not great
and then us residents uh had a higher
satisfaction compared to Canadian
residents that was for a couple of
reasons I think but obviously we're
coming out of covid as well and
especially for some of our Canadian
markets coming back after that year was
was definitely super
tough but then the fun part also is we
can cut this by a ton of different ways
so we can cut it by other survey
questions uh seat location other tbts
questions by club and so I have a couple
examples to share with you guys today
and a little bit of a quiz
actually so if we look first by season
ticket member uh net promoter score by
tenure so the number of Seasons that
they've been a season ticket member how
many people think if you've been a
season ticket member for longer so you
have longer tenure maybe 20 years you
have a higher net promoter score than
someone who's a rookie
account nobody all right good job yeah
uh so uh basically our rookie accounts
interestingly enough had a higher
satisfaction compared to some of our
older seasoned ticket members but it's
actually kind of interesting because in
sports your most risky accounts aka the
people who are least likely to renew are
actually your rookie accounts uh so
there's a lot of other factors that go
into it so it's it's actually kind of
fun because you get all the old like the
older seasoned ticket members are like I
hate this everything sucks I'm not going
to renew they end up renewing
anyways uh this next one net promoter
score by ticket price so who thinks
someone who paid more for their tickets
had a better experience or a higher net
promoter
score all right probably like two three
people all right the majority was right
uh so the good news well the bad news
actually is that our highest paying
season ticket members had the lowest net
promoter score again bad news if the
people that are paying the most the most
money are the least satisfied not great
for our industry
and then this uh this last one well I
have one more but this is last quiz uh
uh single game buyer net promoter score
by based on where they sit in the arena
so if you think raise your hand if you
think if they sat closer to the ice AK
they were in the lower bowl they had a
higher
satisfaction H maybe like a quarter is
of the room jokes on you guys it doesn't
make a difference so interestingly
enough it was actually pretty flat based
on where you were sitting uh within the
arena and then talking about how we
really taking this information to drive
decision-making at our clubs this is
looking at net promoter score by all of
our different uh ticket packages so
something that we say in sports and
we're trying to understand is is the
season ticket package dead especially in
the NHL when there's 41 45 games reality
of someone coming to all those games is
not is is not likely and so you'll see
here our full season ticket uh members
have the lowest net promoter scort and
then it starts to go up once you get
into those smaller packages with our
quarters and minis being the most
satisfied but you'll see we actually at
the time had eight clubs who weren't
offering quarter season ticket packages
so we could then take this information
go into those eight markets and say hey
do you realize that that has a highest
satisfaction but you don't offer that
and maybe we should start to split up
rather than offering 41 games maybe 11
game plan for
example I'd also be remissed to say net
promoter score is not the only way to
measure fan satisfaction um so you'll
see actually on the Le hand side that
net promoter score like we we saw it
went down year-over year but we also
asked about overall game day
satisfaction and actually increased
year-over-year and so it's really
important as you're developing surveys
is not just look at it in one form or
fashion cut this data by a bunch of
different ways and also ask a different
questions about overall satisfaction my
favorite and least favorite question is
asking about season ticket member value
because value means so many different
things to so many different people and I
know I only have 19 seconds left but
luckily this is the shortest part of my
presentation um stepping into what I
kind of oversee now we have kind of
three main areas so Market intelligence
is basically our internal consultants
for our marketing and our Partnerships
team uh business intelligence is
basically our main stakeholders for our
ticket sales and service team uh
overseeing our CRM as well and then
finally ticket operations they are The
Unsung heers of sports organizations if
they did not exist no one would ever get
their tickets um but one of our main
focuses as we're getting started again
our only our department has only existed
for about 10 11 months uh is building a
really good found foundation and
building out our report catalog so over
the last 10 months our team has been
super hard at work basically putting
together all these different reports and
there're still a ton more to come I wish
I had more time to present some of these
um but just showing a little bit of
insight of now with our team joining
this was our renewal report uh for the
last couple of Seasons it was basically
just a you know kind of a plain
spreadsheet now with our team coming in
understanding the the value uh and power
of Tableau we can take that chart and
then instead create
which is just a much more visual way to
look at some of this data so our ticket
s our VP of ticket sales and service can
go in and see all right we're on the
21th day of renewal we've lost X number
of seats but we're still pacing behind
the last three years which is really
great news um don't have enough time to
to cover this slide but just wanted to
say thank you so much uh I love going
through all this data I could talk about
it for probably hours this actually used
to be an hourong presentation so it was
nice to kind of cut it down to 20
minutes but thank you so much I
appreciate it hope you guys learned uh
learn a little bit just how we're
looking at this in sports so thank
you